السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه المباشره
والمستمره والمتواصله لاحداث السودان
المؤسفه والمؤلمه اليوم تدخل الاسماء
اسبوعها الثاني بحصيله ثقيله من القتلى
والجرحى سواء في صفوف الجيش والدعم السريع
او حتى المدنيين حيث افادت منظمه الصحه
العالميه بان اكثر من 400 شخص قتلوا في
المواجهات وذلك بعد اسبوع من المواجهات
والاشتباكات المستمره ايضا بدات الشوارع
تفوح برائحه الجثث المستشفيات تعجز عن
التنفس جراء الاعداد الهائله للجرحى اما
المطارات فلا تزال مغلقه سواء للداخلين او
الخارجين
[موسيقى]
اذا رغم الهدنه المعلنه تتواصلوا
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وسط الصناع يدوي
انفجارات في ام درمان مع تحليق للطائرات
الحربيه واطلاق نار في محيط القصر الرئاسي
الانباء متضاربه ايضا حول عمليات الطرفين
العسكريه حيث شهدت وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
ومحيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه شهدت
اشتباكات عنيفه واعلن الطرفان السيطره على
وسط الخرطوم والقياده العامه فمن جهتها
قالت القوات البريه للجيش السوداني انها
تسيطر على محيط القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه في الخرطوم اما قوات الدعم السريع
فقد نشرت صورا لما قالت انه انتشار
لعناصرها في شوارع وسط الخرطوم فيما نفى
الجيش ذلك كما نشرت دعم السريع او نشرت
الدعم السريع صورا للاستيلاء على مدرعات
عسكريه في شارع مدني بالعاصمه
الله اكبر
على كل المواقع الاستراتيجيه الحيويه على
مستوى الدوله السودانيه
نحن كقوات الدعم السريع معروفين بالقتال
والشراسه
عن حقنا وندافع عن الشعب السوداني
وحمايه الديموقراطيه والحريه والسلام
والعداله في واحنا هدفنا كله المواطن
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي خالد الفك
اهلا بك معنا خالد بدايه هل لك ان ترصد
لنا مجريات المعارك في الخرطوم يعني هناك
حديث عن هدنه ولكن قبل قليل كنا نستمع الى
طلق نار بما يعني ان هناك ربما خروقات
لهذه الهدنه انقل لنا الصوره لديك
يعني اعتقد ان هذه الهدنه تم خرقها منذ
ساعات الاولى لاعلانها حيث اننا الان كاد
اسمع دوي ادانات في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم
نحوي 22 كيلو من مطرح العمليات الاول كما
ان هناك حديث وانباء تتواتر عن وقوع
اشتباك قوي وسمه انفجارات في ضاحيه او في
احياء حله حمد واخويلي والتي تقع في مدينه
بحري قباله القطر الرئاسي مباشره حيث ان
هناك كانت مركز واضح وكبير للدعم السريع
في مقر فندق الصداقه وتم يعني اسقاط بعض
الصواريخ عليه من قبل القوات المسلحه في
وقت سابق لكن يبدو ان عمليه القرض وان
تعمل سريع يعني يحاول ان يفتح مسار
واطلاق سلسله امداد لقواته التي هي
التي هي الان ترتكز داخل القصر الرئاسي
لان لا يفصل بين هذا
بنقصر الجمهوري وفندق الصداقه سواء النيل
فقط
يعني هذا من الناحيه الشرقيه وهذا من
الناحيه
عفوا هذه من ناحيه الجنوبيه وهذا من
الناحيه الشماليه يبدو ان هناك ايضا تمت
معارك تدور في منطقه قريه العسكريه ولكن
لا لا يعني هي تبدو اقل خفه واقل حده ايضا
هناك سمعنا عن اشتباكات وتجدد اشتباكات في
محيط
احياء الصحافه والامتداد بين القوات
المسلحه
والدعم السريع ايضا وفقي شهود عيان ان
هناك مازال تمركز لبعض من افراد الدعم
السريع في جسم ارتكازات داخل بعض الاحياء
في ولايه الخرطوم ولكن اللافت بالامس ما
تم
م باشيان ملاحظه ومداهمه القوات المسلحه
للدعم السريع خارج ولايه الخرطوم وشهدنا
ان هناك قوه اصبحت في الطريق القومي
الخرطوم المدني وسمت اشتباك اشتباكات في
محيط مدن النوبه ومدن المسؤوليه
وربما هذا لاول مره ان تنتقل للعمليات من
من داخل المركز العمليات الرئيسي الذي
وقعت فيه الاولى الى خارج العاصمه بنحو
100 كيلو ما سبب خروجها الى خارج العاصمه
خالد عينها للجيش يحسم المعركه داخل
الخرطوم بالتالي يتراجعون الى خارجها
نعم نعم يعني يبدو واضحا يبدو واضحا
القوات المسلحه بنيت على محاوله
وضعي خطوط
وفتح مسارات تراجع لتعمل السريع وتقليل
قوته الموجوده كانت
بكميات كبيره في الايام الاولى داخل
المناطق الافتراضيه لو كان في المطار او
سواء كان في محيط القياده العامه او التي
كانت في اطراف العاصمه وجنوب العاصمه
تحديدا
الجيش قال في بيانات السابقه بانه يعني
يطلق حمله كبيره للمسح الجوي والبري
وبالامس شاهدنا يعني قوه كبيره من
الجيش يقوم بالمسح الامني والبري ولكن
ذكرت لي بان قوات الدعم السريع يعني
يرتكزون داخل الاحياء المدنيه بالتالي كيف
يميز الجيش المدنيين من اعضاء الدعم
السريع
نعم يعني هذه وحده من الاشكاليات
والتحديات التي
الجيش في حسم المعرفه بشكل كلي وهو يعني
لجوء بعض
وسيارات الدفاع الروائي للدعم السريع
للاختباء في الاحياء وتحتل الاشجار وبقرب
المنازل بشكل مجموعات يعني ما بين 15 الى
سبعه
تاثيرات يعني فبالتالي هم الان يحاولون ان
يتفادوا الغزو الذي يعني بعد واضحا وهدف
استراتيجي من القوات المسلحه فاذا نجدهم
هم الان المعارك اصبحت تدور في احياء جنوب
الخرطوم واحياء في شكل الشركه النيل وايضا
يعني
في اخذ مسارات في مطاردات في الشارع
القومي الرابط بين ولايه الجزيره وولايه
الخرطوم تعطي ان يعني
بل سمعنا امس ان الدعم السريع يحاول ان
يضرر شخصيه
قياديه من خلال بعض يعني كان هناك ركله من
السيارات الدعم السريع
ويتوسطها
عربه بيضاء
الفيديوهات نشرت يعتقد ان ان الدعم السريع
يحاول ان يهرب احد قياداته الى خارج بلاد
الخرطوم من المحاوله
خالد ابقى معي لنشير بان ثاني ايام العيد
او عيد الفطر اقبل مشاهدينا والحرب مستمره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع ولا يزال
السودانيون يتعثرون بين مخلفات الدمار
الذي طال بيوتهم نتيجه القصف المتبادل بين
الجانبين
لا عيدا في استقبال زائر ولا حديثا
مستعجلا عند الوداع قست الجدران على
صاحبها في قلبها سواد دمار لا غير يتعرف
هذا الرجل على منزل تغيرت ملامحه انقلب
راسا على عقب
والارض لا تسعه وان مدت له يد العون
حديث الرصاص في صباحات العيد احتفظ المكان
بالادله قذيفه ورصاصات طائشه يخمن محمود
الطيب تفاصيل ما حل بمنزله وسط العديد في
العاصمه الخرطوم
الحديد اللي فوق القزازه القزاز هنا بتاع
العربيه وهنا في غطاء كده من الحديد ضربت
هنا وقعت زي المسافه دي قدام رجله النزهه
اهل الدار تركوا ورائهم حادثه بيت مدمر
نجحوا الى ولايات سودانيه مجاوره بعيدا عن
ساحه الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
مئات السودانيين نزحوا الى ولايات مجاوره
للخرطوم شمالا وجنوبا مناطق وان كانت
بعيده نسبيا عن الاشتباكات الا ان خارطه
المعارك تنذر بامتداد الصراع محتدم الى
اطراف الخرطوم وابعد غيداء السالم العربيه
نعود الى الخرطوم وظيفي من هناك خالد
الفكري يعني خالد اعود اليك لنتحدث قليلا
عن مجريات المعارك كذلك والجثث التي تنتشر
في شوارع الخرطوم هل لك ان تحدثنا عن ذلك
كيف هو الوضع تحديدا
من التحديات التي
الطبيه والصحيه وعدم الوصول الى هذه الجثث
التي ظهرت في بعض المقاطع الفيديوهات
بانها ملقاه بكثافه في الطرقات والشوار
الان
الدوائر والقطاعات الصحيه تطالب دي ضروره
فتح مسارات امنه لها حتى تستطيع انتاج هذه
الجثث
وايضا تقديم العون اللازم
هذه الجثث خالد يبدو ان هناك قصف يحدث
الان في محيط المطار في الخرطوم لنستمع
قليلا
اذا في ظل دخولنا لليوم الثاني من ايام
عيد الفطر المبارك والاسبوع الثاني من
الاشتباكات ورغم الهدنه المتوقعه خلال
ايام العيد الا ان هناك خروقات وهناك
اشتباكات متواصله ومستمره وطلق نار كما
نستمع الان في هذه الصور المباشره التي
ننظر اليها من خلال كاميرا العربيه في
محيط مطار العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اعود
اليك خالد يعني هذه الاشتباكات المستمره
وخصوصا في محيط المطار يعني ما مدى خطوره
ذلك يعني نعلم
انه يقع في وسط المدينه بين البيوت
والمنازل هل هل ذلك صحيح
تماما
مطابق الثوم يقع في وسط المدينه بشكل
مباشر
[موسيقى]
ثم فضلوا مغادره منازله واخلاقها
الاوضاع بطبيعتها وتفضلوا الذهاب الى
منازل تبعد تكون امنه بعيده من دائره
الاشتباك سواء كان داخل ولايه الخرطوم
جنوبا او في شيء جميل او حتى في الولايات
الضريبه مثل الابيض او النيل الازرق لانه
يبدو ان الطرفان سواء كانوا اخوات المسلحه
يريدان الالتزام بالهدنه خالد دعني انقل
هذه الفكره الى ضيفي ايضا من الخرطوم
المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين اهلا بك سعاده الفريق يعني خالد
الفكيه يتحدث عن ان الطرفان لا يرغبان على
ما يبدو في اتمام هذه الهدنه او حتى في
وقف النار خلال ايام العيد عسكريا سعاده
الفريق كيف يمكن التعامل مع الاشتباكات
هذه
المستمره يعني نستمع الان الى صوت مدفعي
الى طلق نار لنستمع قليلا ثم اعود اليك
سعاده الفريق
اذا في اليوم الثاني من ايام عيد الفطر
المبارك كما ذكرنا قبل قليل مشاهدينا
اشتباكات وتبادل لاطلاق النار شمال القصر
الرئاسي في الخرطوم اشتباكات حول محيط
المطار ايضا في الخرطوم كان الصحفي خالد
الفقيه يتحدث قبل قليل بان الاشتباكات على
ما يبدو بدات تبتعد عن وسط العاصمه وتذهب
الى محيط العاصمه وخارج ايضا حدود العاصمه
على ما يبدو عمليات المسح من قبل الجيش
مجالات مستمره في الخرطوم الدعم السريع
يعني يرتكزون بين المنازل والمدنيين ايضا
كما تحدث خالد الفكي سعاده الفريق اعود
اليك عسكريا كيف يمكن التعامل مع عناصر
الدعم السريع او المتمركزين داخل المناطق
المدنيه
للمتابعين يعني
مرارا وتكرارا قلنا ان قوات الدعم السريعه
الان فاقده تماما السيطره على عناصرها
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تتنفس اي هدنه كلما
يتم هذا انا اعتقد انه فقط
لتبييض الوجه اتجاه امام المجتمع الاقليمي
والدولي فان الراغبون
ندخل في هدنه انسانيه لمصلحه المواطن ولكن
حقيقه الدعم السريع السيطره تماما على
قواده الان معظم قواته معظم قواته اتخذت
الى مجموعات صغيره تعمل باسلوب حرب
العصابات
على المواطنين تذهب الممتلكات الخاصه
تذهب في بعض الاحيان
وهذا المسلحه يعني ويجب عليها ان تتعامل
مع هذه الفوضى وان تزعزعها الى حجمها
ونعتقد انه جاء الا حسب هذه الفوضى ما
يحدث الان
اسمها عسكريا سعاده الفريق مع اقل خسائر
من الارواح المدنيه
لكن عدد من الخسائر غير مقبوله يعني
تعمل على السريع يتخذ من حي المطار حي
المطار هذا
يضع لاصق تماما مع القياده العامه
مدرج المطار
سكن لكبار
المسؤولين في الدوله الجامعات واضباط
نظاميه
ومنذ اليوم الاول
كانت يعني تتولى حراسه هذا الموقع لانه
فيه منزل حميد
تقريبا
ودلوع بشريه تحسنوا خلفها ولذلك حتى الان
الرواتب المسلحه لم تتعامل معه في هذا
الموقع رغم انه هذا الموقع هو سبب الازعاج
بسبب ان هنالك جزء من مطار الخرطوم خارج
سيدنا المسلحه
الفريق تدور حول محيط المطار وتدور حول
القصر الرئاسي كذلك كيف تسري هذه المعارك
وما الذي يحدث تحديدا وانا اتحدث عسكري
كل هذه المعارك تنطلق من اماكن يتمركز
فيها عناصر الدعم السريعه تتخذ من بعض
الابرياء دروع بشريه تحتمي بهم من مهاجمه
القوات المسلحه يخرجون في لحظه معينه
يهجمون على القوات التي تحمل مصر او التي
تحمل قياده العامه ثم يعود الى هذه
المناطق التي يتحسنون فيها هذا هو المشهد
تماما وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه يعني الغاز
المسلحه تتعامل مع هذه الاماكن التي فيها
دروع بكثير جدا من الصف
تنفذ ما لديهم من ذخائر
وبعد ذلك بالتاكيد سيهربون ويسلمونه
انفسنا
بالحديث عن الهروب وتسليم النفس يعني هناك
انباء تحدثت سعاده الفريق عن السجون في
الخرطوم وان بعض من عناصر الدعم السريع
يطلقون سراح السجناء وهذه اتهامات من قبل
الجيش ما صحه ذلك
من المجرمين
انفجار مخدرات ومتهمين في جرائم
جماعيه بعقوبات طويله وهذا بالتاكيد سيخلق
حاله من عدم الاستقرار الامني لفتره قد
تطول بالعاصمه جهدنا قبل
ذلك اللي كانت تسمى عضو في مجلس السياده
4000 من المجرمين سجن الهدى هذا يعني
الامن في الخرطوم على مدى سنتين بسبب
هؤلاء الاربعه الف الذين تم اطلاق سراحهم
هكذا عبثا
اطلق صراحه من السجون سعاده الفريق وفتيل
المواجهه بين الجيش والدعم السريع وصل الى
ابواب السجون سعاده الفريق ابقى معي لانه
اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع
بالهجوم على سجن الهدى في ام درمان واطلاق
سراح عدد كبير من النزلاء في المقابل
مشاهدينا نفت قوات الدعم السريع ما وصفتها
بمزاعم متداوله على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي عن اقتحام عناصرها لسجن الهدى
في ام درمان واطلاق سراح السجناء وقالت في
بيان لها انها نبهت سابقا في بيان من
عمليات توزيع لذي قواتها على عناصر وصفتهم
بالفولول لتنفيذ اعمال اجراميه والصاق
التهمه في الدعم السريع اعود اليك سعاده
الفريق اذا انت تؤكد بانه تم بالفعل اطلاق
سراح بعض السجناء لماذا يقومون بذلك الدعم
السريع ما الهدف
الدعم السريع بالنسبه
له اصبحت اصبح خارج السيطره يريدون ان
يخلفوا حاله من الفوضى
الترويع المواطنين وحاله من الارباك
للاجهزه الامنيه قبل ان
ان هنالك جهاز ترتدي زي الدعم الفريز
ترتكب الجرائم باسمه يعني كلنا نعلم من هو
الفنون الذين يقصدونهم ونعلم من هي ما هي
القوات المسلحه والمواطنين يعلم ان هذا
ليس من سلوك ولا من ثقافه للقوات المسلحه
ولا الذين يصفونهم بالفلوس ولكن
القوات اتولد على مستودع الشجره للدعم
السريع وجدت فيه 8000 لب
سه هذا المسلحه اذا
جدا الان نجد
عناصر
لها وتهاجم الاعباك العامه والخاصه
وكل ما نجاهد يقول هذه وهذا المسلحه ولكن
هي عناصر الدعم هي صاحبه هذه الفرقه وهي
التي ممكن ان تنفذ هذا العمل انا اقول لك
عزيزتي الان القوات المسلحه افرض السيطره
شبه كامله الان ما يريدون الان في شمال
القصر في منطقه
قلنالك قوات من الدعم الشريعه كانت تتحسن
في هذا القوات المسلحه فرضت عليها حصارا
حتى تنفق ما لديها من مون وتستسلم ولكنهم
الان تقريبا لانه وصل للرمخه الاخير اصروا
على ان يقتحموا هذا الحصار
وغالبا لكي يولوا هاربين ولذلك تدور هذه
محمد يحلها
هذه المعارك سعاده الفريق يعني نقابه
اطباء السودان يقولون في هذا العاجل
امامنا على الشاشه بان ثلاثه عشره مستشفى
تعرضت للقصف وتسعه عشر اضطرت الى الاخلاء
القصري اذا المستشفي المستشفيات السودان
بالتالي تعاني بالفعل حسب نقابه اطباء
السودان مشاهدينا هذه اصوات للاشتباكات
واطلاق النار نستمع اليها مباشره عبر
كاميرا العربيه في الخرطوم اشتباكات حتى
اللحظه مستمره وفي تصاعد رغم الهدنه
المعلنه ورغم دخولنا ثاني ايام العيد
وثاني اسبوع من هذه الاشتباكات والمواجهات
العربيه اول وسيله اعلاميه تتمكن من تصوير
قاعده الدعم السريع في منطقه جبل سركاب
شمال ام درمان وكانت قوات الجيش السوداني
قد سيطرت على القاعده قبل ايام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قاعده سركاب كانت معسكر خاصا بجهاز الامن
والمخابرات قبل اندلاع الثوره ديسمبر
القاعده تقع بالجوار من منطقه كرر
العسكريه
تجاور القاعده بعض فروع القوات المسلحه
كالقوات الخاصه والمحموله جوا في اطار
المنطقه العسكريه
معسكر سيركاب تحول لقاعده عملياتيه توفر
الامداد والتعيينات تعد بحسب الخبراء
العسكريين موقعا استراتيجيا
اعود الى الخرطوم وظيفي من هناك المحلل
العسكريه الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين
سعاده الفريق يعني
سيطره الجيش على قاعده السركاب في منطقه
كرري هل لها اي اهميه عسكريه استراتيجيه
كما سمعنا في التقرير السابق
وليس
استخدمها كانت دعم السريع للاستعوا خساره
من كل المواد الغتاليه يستخدمها
تاخذ فيها قواته وقسطا من الراحه الان كل
هذه القصيده الطبقات المسلحه يعني في توبه
في
صالح شركات في كرري في
هذه كلها كانت معسكرات ضخمه للدفاع
للدعم السريع والان كلها
القوات المس
لحه الدعم السريع فاقد للسيطره تماما كما
ذكرت لك
القيادات يعني متابعين الان اختفى تماما
من المشهد باداه الصف الاول للصف الثاني
الصف الثالث حتى لا يوجد يعني لو لاحظت
حتى كل الفيديوهات المتداوله لا نشاهد
فيها ضابط بروده العميد يعني هذا معناه
حتى الصف الثالث من عناصر الدم السريع اما
قتل او قتل او هرب خارج الخرطوم وهذه نقطه
مهمه سعاده الفريق يعني اود ان انقلها الى
خالد الفكي خالد يعني منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات لا لم نرى اي ظهور لحميدتي او
دقلو لم نرى اي ظهور لعبد الرحيم كذلك
لقائد الثاني للدعم السريع والشقيق الاخ
الغير شقيق
لم نرى ظهور اعلامي لهم استمعنا الى
مداخلات هاتفيه نعم في بدايه الاشتباكات
لكن لا ظهور على عكس البرهان الذي ظهر
بالامس او او قبل امس يهنئ المواطنين
بالعيد وظهر قبله بفيديو قصير ايضا لا
نعلم مكان هذا الفيديو ما دلالات ذلك خالد
دلالات كبيره في المتعلق باداره المعركه
واداره الازمه
وتاكيد على رفع روح القوه في الميدان
التاكيد على ان هذه القياده موجوده
وتدير هذه الازمه والمعرفه بنفسها من خلال
مشاهدناه وربما خلال اليوم الاول اشهدنا
فيديو عبد الفتاح البرهان بجان
[موسيقى]
للسياده ياسر العظمه وهو يتجول بين القوات
ويهنون بالعيد
ويحسهم على النصر فاذا هذه الفيديوهات
ظهرت لقيادات من القوات المسلحه دون شكل
لها تاثير بالغ في رفح معنويه للجنود
والضباط المقيمين في الميدان وكذلك هي
تنعكس سلبا على اغوار الدم السريعه التي
شعر الفريق انت ان لم يظهر حتى هذه اللحظه
لغايه الثاني واظل يتحدث بالصوت او يغرد
في تغريدات يعني كانت بالامس يعني يعني كل
التقريرات ظلت تتحدث عن المجتمع الدولي
وتواصله معه
ودعمه للديمقراطيه والسلام وتحقيق اهداف
الثوره كانما اراد ان يدقق مشاعر يعني
السودانيين في هذا الامر رغم ان كان موقفه
منذ الاول واضحا فبالتالي الان يبدو ان
الحسم الميداني من خلال المؤشرات والدلائل
وما ياتي من بيانات متلاحقه من النقل
الرسمي من خلال ما ياتينا من مصادر شهود
عيانه على افضل ميدان
بعد العالقين الذين لا يستطيعون القرود في
مناطق شبه امنه وان كانت في دائره الاحداث
الان الجيش الذهبي في خطته بابعاد الدعم
السريع والقوه الاكبر من محيط الفائده
الحديثي والفعل الحقيقي ومسح العمليات
الاول
فهذا يعني يشير الى ان
الاستراتيجيه والظاهره
في تدرجات مختلفه وفقي
الميدان المعرفه وفقي ما لديه من قوه
وادوات سواء كان المتعلقه بالقران الحربي
او بالمدرعات او بالمشاه او اخرى سمعنا ان
هناك فرق متخصصه في المظلات وفرقه في
الطوارئ لمحاوله فك الحصار على بعض
المناطق او انزال بالقوه المحوله القوى
الجويه فاذا هناك قرارات فيما يبدو افضل
للقوات المسلحه من الدعم السريع الذي هو
الان يعني يحاول ان يفتح خطوط وسلسله
امداد لبعض قضاه المتواجدين داخل بعض
المقار السياريه او الرئاسيه ولكن يبدو ان
الان بما يفعله الجيش من خلال يعني
الضربات المتواليه والاستباقيه
ابدا يبدو الان على الاقل عمليا في حتى
هذا اليوم الثامن ان عمليا وعلى الواقع
الميداني فهناك تفوق واضح للجيش
واستراتيجيه فيما يبدو كما ذكرت خالد
والاستراتيجيه التي يستخدمها الجيش يعني
هناك دعوات دوليه واماميه ومناشدات بوقف
اطلاق النار بالالتزام بالهدنه وايضا هناك
محاولات من عده دول لاجلاء مواطنيهم
ودبلوماسيهم داخل السودان مراسل العربيه
ذكر في العاجل الذي امامنا على الشاشه بان
بريطانيا تريد عقد طموحه في مجلس الامن
حول السودان خلال يومين لانتقل الى مروي
ومراسل العربيه هناك نزار بقداوي نزار
اهلا بك معنا يعني في هذا العاجل بريطانيا
تتحدث عن عقد جلسه مفتوحه في مجلس الامن
حول السودان هل من مطالبات الدوليه اخرى
هل هناك اي منباء من خارج السودان عما
يحدث داخل السودان
الان تفاعل الغربي والتفاعل الدولي
والتفاؤل الاقليمي وحتى التفاؤل الداخلي
هنا في السودان كل هذه
تدفع بقوه نحو وقف ما يدور من اقتتال ومن
عمليات عسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع الان نحن نتحدث عن شان اليوم لهذه
العمليات العسكريه وكل المنظومه الدوليه
والغربيه قالقه على مستويات متعدده
المستوى الاول على وضعيه من هم يمثلون
هؤلاء هذه الدول سواء كانت تلك الدبلوماسي
او رعايه هذه الدول وعلى مستويات اخرى
الاشارات الوارده من المنظمه الامميه
تحديدا من الامين العام للامم المتحده
وعدد من الدول في مجلس الامن بضروره وقف
التصعيد العسكري لحمايه المدنيين وسكان
ايضا الحديث حول ضروره ان يتاح الطبيه
للصليب الاحمر
ولمنظمات الغوص حتى تساهم وتساعد المدنيين
وتساعد المتاثرين والمتضررين وحتى تصل
المساهمه والمساعده في تاهيل
وتقديم الدعم والسند للمرافق الصحيه نحن
نقول وننقل الافادات الوارده من وزاره
الصحه السودانيه الخرطوم الان تضم نحو
مستشفى ما بين الخاص وما بين العام اكثر
من 70% من هذه النسبه التضررت جراء عمليات
القصف وعمليات الاشتباكات هذا يعني تحدي
حقيقي في القطاع الصحي ما يدور الان في
السودان يشغل المجتمع الدولي يشغل الدول
الاقليم البيانات تصدر ساعه بعد ساعه من
مختلف الواجهات سواء كان من قبل الاتحاد
الافريقي او من الجامعه العربيه او من
الدول المحيطه بالسودان وحتى من مجلس
الامن انقل الان يشعر بالغلق تجاه ما يحدث
في السودان طيب نزار يعني هناك احاديث
كثيره عن محاولات عده دول لاجلاء مواطنيهم
ودبلوماسيهم هناك حديث عن القاعدات
العسكريه ان كان الامريكيه او اليابانيه
في جيبوتي ولكن مطار مروي وبما انه الوضع
هناك هادئ نوعا ما هل يمكن استخدامه
لاجلاء المواطنين
هذا الامر الان هو
رهن
ومتحكم فيه والقرار الاخير ياتي من قبل
القياده العسكريه سواء تخرج الاشاره من
مروي بان هذا المطار الان على هوبه
الاستعداد لاستقبال طائرات سواء كانت
عسكريه او مدنيه لاجلاء رعايه اي دوله
تطلب ذلك لكن الان
الوضع في مطار مروي هو بيد السلاح
المهندسين سلاح المهندسين منوض به ان يقدم
تقريرا مفصليا يوضح هل هذا المطار الان
بامكانه ان يستقبل لان المطار كان ساحه
حرب كان مسرعا لاشتباكات كان مسرحا
للنوعيات مختلفه من الاسلحه منها منفجر
ومنها من لم ينفجر لا بد من تمشيط وتنظيف
وتهيئه المطار
ليمارس مهامه الجويه والمداحيه
اذا هذا الامر ولم تكمل فرق الس
التابعه للجيش السوداني هذه المهام لا
يمكن الحديث الان عن قدره استقبال مطار
مروي او القاعده العسكريه في مروي لاي
طائرات او اجلاء اي رعايه لاي من الدول
التي تطالب الان بان يتاح لها عدد من
المطارات وعدد من المعابط في السودان حتى
يتسنى لها اجراء هذا الامر العاجل الطاري
القرار فقط بيد الجيش هو الذي يؤكد هذه
المعلومات هذا عن وضع مطار مروي ولكن ماذا
عن الوضع في محيط المطار وفي مروي بشكل
عام يعني هل هناك مخاوف من ربما عوده
عناصر الدعم السريع محاولات اعاده الهجوم
او السيطره على المنطقه
الجيش اكد غير مره بان الامور تحت السيطره
تماما هو الان يتابع ما يحدث في عدد من
المدن السودان لكن فيما يلي حدود
المسؤوليه للفرقه التاسعه عشره مشاه هنا
في مروي حيث نوجد ونتحدث الجيش يقول بانه
يحكم السيطره ويؤكد على هذه السيطه هو
الذي يمسك بزمام الامر وزمام المبادره
ينتشر في عدد من المناطق في عدد من
الوحدات يعمل على تامين المرافق
الاستراتيجيه يعمل عبر رسائله في التوجيه
المعنوي بطمنه المواطنين ان مروي الان
امنه مستقره لا يوجد فيها اي وجود لعناصر
وقوات الدعم السريع على المواطنين ان
يساهموا لرفع الروح المعنويه لمن يمسكون
بزمام الامر في هذه المنطقه وحداد عسكريه
مختلفه الان موجوده في مروي العتاده
العسكري يقول الجيش بانه يمكن ان يعين
ويمكن ان يساهم في حسم اي موقف قد يشهده
او تشهده المنطقه في اي وقت لكن كل
سيناريوهات الان يتحسب لها الجيش بحكم ان
المرحله هي مرحله الاستعداد والجيش
والقوات في مرحله استعداد بنسبه 100 حتى
قبل اندلاع هذه الاشتباكات قبل ثمانيه
ايام شكرا
على هذه المعلومات
وتعليقا على ذلك قال مصطفى ادم احمد مدير
منظمه الزرقاء للتنميه ان محاولات جمع
الجثث المتناثره في شوارع الخرطوم باتت
تشكل عمليه معقده لاسيما المساحه الواسعه
التي تنتشر فيها ومشكله تحلل هذه الجثث ما
يشكل خطرا على الوضع الصحي والبيئي في
المدينه
وهو موضوع انساني في
المقام الاول جمع الجثث موضوع شاق لانه
الجزء واخذ ثمن اطويه اصبحت تتحلل مجموعه
من الشباب والطوعين مجموعه من لمس شكلت
بالتنسيق مع المنظمات منظمه الزرقاء وغيره
من المنصه الناشطين بانه يتم تجميع هذه
الجثث وفي الاول كيفيه تجميع الاكفان
والاقفان اصبحت مشكله يعني تجمع الطعم في
الطبيعيين وفي ناس متبرعين
من الاجفان التي نظن الشغل الشاغل بالنسبه
في اطار المنظمات في اطار كيفيه يعني حصر
هذه الجثث هو موالات الثرى بحيث انه لا
تشكل
كبير جدا
بالمقام الاول
في هذا السياق اكدت رئيسه اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر مريانا سبوليريتش ان تعذر
وصول المساعدات الى السودان يعود بالاساس
الى عدم تقديم طرفي النزاع ضمانات امنيه
ودعت رئيسه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
دعت الاطراف المعنيه الى تمكين فرقها من
ايصال المساعدات من دون عراقيل واضافت
المسؤوله ان اولويه اللجنه هي تقديم
المساعده الطبيه للمستشفيات في السودان
معربه عن استعداد المنظمه لايصال مزيد من
الامدادات فور توقف القتال
كما اعلن الهلال الاحمر او السوداني عن
تعرض مخازنه في الخرطوم بحري للسطو بواسطه
افراد المسلحين وقال الهلال الاحمر ان
مسلحين مجهولين نهبوا ثمانيه سيارات ذات
دفع رباعي وشاحنه وشاحنه تتبع للجمعيه
لافتا الى ان الاطراف او اطراف النزاع
ستسعى لمساعدته في استعاده سيارات
المسروقه وحضر الهلال الاحمر من ان سوء
استخدام السيارات المسروقه التابعه له
ستؤدي لعواقب وخيمه لا سيما تلك التي تحمل
شعار الهلال الاحمر
بدوره قال سكرتير النقابه الاطباء
السودانيه عطيه عبد الله عطيه قال ان اقل
من عشره مستشفيات تعمل في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم حيث باتت هي الاخرى
مهدده بالانهيار وسط استمرار الاشتباكات
بين طرفي النزاع
المنتجات يمكن التي يعني تعمل الان هي اقل
من عشره مستشفيات تعمل بصوره جيده واغلبها
هو عرضه للتوقف في اي لحظه نقص الامداد
نقص الكوادر
لا هدنه تصمد ولا عيد يشفع فاللغه الخصوم
تحتد اكثر ويكثر الرصاص يسمع صداه هنا
يسقط مدنيون ويتداعى قطع باكمله قتلى
وجرحى بالعشرات اكثر من 600 قتيل ومئات
الجرح بحسب وزاره الصحه السودانيه اعداد
تضغط على قطاع طبي على وشك الانهيار
خروج متوالي لعدد من المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه وايضا هنالك عدد من المستشفيات
الاخرى ايضا هي على حافه الاغلاق وزاره
الصحه السودانيه قالت
مستشفيات تعمل بكامل طاقتها في الخرطوم
وبينت ان عشره مستشفيات حكوميه خرجت عن
الخدمه في العاصمه نقابه الاطباء قالت ان
14 مستشفى تعرضت للقصف في البلاد بينما
يعمل نحو 23 مستشفى بشكل جزئي لكنها مهدده
بالاغلاق
[موسيقى]
الكوادر الطبيه
وفي ظل ظروف صعبه تعمل منظمات دوليه
واماميه لدعم القطاع الطبي المنهك لكن
القتال يعقد اي مسعا لذلك منظمه اطباء بلا
حدود قالت ان فريقها الطبي لم يتمكن من
ادخال امدادات طبيه اضافيه الى السودان
المنظمه اشارت الى ان الامدادات في مستشفى
الفاشر مثلا تكفي لثلاثه اسابيع فقط
نعود الى الخرطوم والصحفي خالد الفكري
ارحب بك مجددا خالد يعني مع ازمه الجثث
هذه وانتشارها في الشوارع مل خيارات
المطروحه لحل هذه الازمه حتى الان
الخيارات
الاخلاقيه قبل ان تكون توجهاته معايير من
المنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه بشان التعامل
مع الجثث وفقي المعايير المعلومه والمحدده
فهذا بالتالي ينقلنا ان نقول ان على
الجيش ودعم السريع
الالتزامنه للفرقه العمل الطوعي
لفرغ الانغاز الطبيه
للراغبين في تقديم يد العونه فيما يتعلق
بنقل الجثث والذهاب الى الصفات او قبرها
تعني الاجراءات القانونيه او الرسميه
احيانها فهذا الامر اعتقد انه اخلاقي ومن
ناحيه دينيه على الاقل
هذه
الصور التي نشرها في الفيديوهات التي تبث
عبر العربيه
وكما قالت المصادر الطبيه وقال الطبيه
انها الجزء الان تتعرض للتحلل
نهشي من الكلاب الضاله تتعرض الى ما تت
عرض واشكاليه قانونيه اخرى هو فقدان هويه
هذه الجثه وصعوبه التعرف على
صاحبها في ظل بلاغات كثيفه جدا عن مفقودين
مفقودين وهذا ايضا يكون اشكال جديد فاذا
لابد من فتح المجرات الامنه الان
كل شيء الحديث عن هذه الانثى
والوساطات الاقليميه والدوليه اعتقد انها
ينبغي ان تمنح الاولويه
لستر هذه الجثث
الذين ما زال على قيد الحياه ويعانون ما
يعانون يعني انا يعني لاحظت ان هناك
اهتمام كبير فيما يتعلق
بالتوقف والعدائيات والهدنه
لاجلان دوليه وضغوط دوليه ربما لاخلاء
لاخلاق الرعايه الاجانب فهل فهل يعقل ان
يعني نملا هذه الهدنه
اييي لاغلاق من هو موجود في منطقه امنه
ونترك هذه الجثث بهذه الطريقه البشعه وهذه
يعني اسمح لي ان انقلها الى ضيفي ايضا من
الخرطوم المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين يعني سعاده الفريق يعني نقطه
مهمه طرحها خالد ما ان كان هناك هدنه الى
من ستعطى الاولويه هل ستعطى لاجلاء واخلاء
المواطنين الاجانب والدبلوماسيين ام الى
الوضع الانساني في الداخل السوداني من جثث
ملقاه على الشوارع من الوضع الصحي وما الى
ذلك
مراعاه للظرفه الانساني في المستشفيات صفه
خاصه كانت هذه الهدنه اذا الاولويه لاي
هدنه للوضع الانساني وايضا لكي يتد
طلبات حياتي من الاسواق الغريبه من مكان
سكني
فيما يتعلق انا اعتقد بموضوع الجثث
المتنازل التي يتحدثون
طبعا الموضوع الموضوع معقد ولكن لنستمع
الى هذه الاصوات للاشتباكات المباشره
ساعات الفريق واعود اليك
[موسيقى]
اذا اشتباكات مستمره ومتصاعده في العاصمه
الخرطوم رغم اعلان الهدنه مراسل العربيه
اشار بان هناك سته قتلى في سقوط قذيفه في
منطقه المنصوره وايضا اشعر بان اصوات
انفجارات متواصله وتحليق كثيف للطيران في
منطقه كرري بام درمان ونحن نعلم بان الجيش
سيطره على قاعده عسكريه هناك في كرري
واستمعنا قبل قليل لانفجارات واشتباكات
مستمره ومتواصله في الخرطوم ويشير الى
تحليق كثيف للطيران في العاصمه كذلك طبعا
هذا الطيران تابع للجيش خالد الفكي الصحفي
من الخرطوم كان قد اشار بان المعارك بدات
تبتعد عن وسط العاصمه الى خارجها وحدودها
كذلك اعود اليك سعاده الفريق هل يمكن
التعامل مع ازمه الجثث عسكريا هل يمكن
للجيش التدخل في ذلك
عندما كنت اريد ان اقوله نحن شاهدنا قبل
اربع ايام تقريبا
ففي
معسكر التي
شاهدناه الان قبل اربع ايام كان هذا
المعسكر مليء بالجثث الان الجوله الكاميرا
في نفس المكان ولا توجد ولا جثه واحده هذا
دليل على انه هنالك التعامل مع هذه الجثث
واستترها ايضا تحدث الناطق الرسمي باسم
وزاره الصحه قبل ثلاثه ايام عن ان جمله
الذين سقطوا ضحايا لهذه الاحداث قبل ثلاثه
ايام كانت فقط 107 مواطن سقطوا ضحايا لهذه
الاحداث 107 80 منهم وزاويهم استلموا
جسامينهم وقاموا بعمليه التدريب تبقى 27
جوله الهويه هذه الموجوده في المستشفيات
ان نقابه اطباء
والذين يتحدثوا ايضا في المنظمه الصحه
العالميه في السودان هؤلاء اجسام مسيسه
لهم غرض من هذه النظام الفظيعه الكبيره
التي يتحدثون عنها صحيح نحن نقول الارقام
يعني عرضه لان تزيد ما دامت العمليات
العسكريه المستمره لكن ليس بهذه الفظاعه
هم يريدون ان
يصوروا للعالم ان الوضع كارثي ولكن انا
اؤكد انه الوضع مقدور عليه وتحت السيطره
وحتى الجثث اللي مرت عليها الكاميرا هذه
الان تمر على جثث في بحري كانت بالامس انا
اؤكد لك الان لو ذهبت الكاميرا
لهذه المنطقه سوف لن تجد ولم يستوها واحده
اذا الامر مسيطر عليه هؤلاء يروجون اكاذيب
لغرض الدفع المجتمع الدولي للتدخل ونحن
نقول احترموا زياده السودان دعوا هذه
الازمه الداخليا نحن نعرف كيف نعالج
ازمتنا هذا التمرد الان في نهايته اي من
يدعو الى التوقف هذا القتال لكي نتفاوض
هذا يدعو الى بس الروح من جديد
هذه الدعوات الدوليه والتدخلات الدوليه
كما اسميتها تتعالى الصيحات الدوليه لوقف
الحرب الدائره في السودان وفي هذا السياق
حذرت مجموعه الازمات الدوليه من حرب اهليه
مدمره اذا استمرت الاشتباكات بين طرفي
الحرب المنظمه الدوليه نصحت الجهات
السودانيه الفاعله والجهه الخارجيه ممن
تربطها علاقات مع عبد الفتاح البرهان
ومحمد حمدان المعروف بحميتي ان تطالبهما
بوقف القتال فورا واضافت ان القتال خلف
مئات القتلى وحاصر الالاف متوقعه ان يكون
عدد الوفيات اكبر بكثير كما رجحت ان ينتصر
الجيش على الدعم السريع في الخرطوم وقالت
في حال استطاع الجيش تامين العاصمه وانسحب
حميدتي الى دارفور فمن الممكن ان تتبعها
حرب اهليه وتتوقع الازمات الدوليه ان ما
يحدث ستكون له تبعات اخرى بتاثيره على
الاستقرار في الدول المجاوره مثل التشاد
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ليبيا وجنوب
السودان ونصحت المجموعه الاحزاب السياسيه
وزعماء القبائل بالاستمرار في رفض
الانزياء الانحياز لاطراف معينه ومنع
الشعب من الانخراط في القتال وحثت
اللاعبين الاقليميين لا سيما مصر وتشاد
اثيوبيا وجنوب السودان وارتيريا على تجنب
اي دعم للطرفين
وثقت مقاطع فيديو متداوله على الانترنت
عمليات سلب ونهب في العاصمه الخرطوم
ونيالا باعتبارها ثاني اكبر مدينه تاثرت
بشكل كبير بالحرب مسجله اعلى الخسائر على
المستويين المادي والاقتصادي وكذلك ايضا
على مستوى اعداد القتلى
كسر سمو الكنانه كل الدكاكين تم نحو بصوره
واشياء وحرق
قوه
اسال الله السلامه والعافيه عسى الله يخلف
لهم خيرا مما فقدوا عسى الله يخلف لهم
خيرا مما ف
بعد اسبوعين على المعارك الطاحنه بدات
مهمه اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب مهمه معقده
خاصه مع انتشار المواجهات حول مطار
الخرطوم الدولي وفي هذا السياق اشارت كل
من الامم المتحده وامريكا بريطانيا
اليابان سويسرا وكوريا الجنوبيه والسويد
بالاضافه الى اسبانيا اشارت الى انها تجري
استعدادات او محاولات لابعاد موظفيها من
الخرطوم بعد نحو اسبوع من الاشتباكات في
السودان بدورها اوضحت قوات الدعم السريع
انها مستعده لفتح جميع مطارات السودان
بشكل جزئي حتى تتمكن الحكومات الاجنبيه من
اجلاء رعاياها من دون ان تتضح على الارض
مدى سيطره الدعم السريع على المطارات
مع دخول الاشتباكات في السودان اسبوعها
الثاني اجرى رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه مارك ميلي اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس القوات المسلحه السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان واوضح المتحدث باسم هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه جوزيف هوستيد ان
الطرفين ناقش سلامه المواطنين الامريكيين
وتطورات الاوضاع وما يحدث في السودان
مشاهدينا هذه الصور وفيديو لمواجهات في
الابيض على ما يبدو في السودان
الله اكبر الله اكبر السودان في منطقه
العبيد
[موسيقى]
هذه صور لقوات الجيش نشاهدها امامنا على
الشاشه وتقدم قوات الجيش في الابيض في
كردوغان
اذا عناصر من افراد الجيش يظهرون امامنا
في هذا الفيديو الذي نشاهده يهللون
ويكبرون فرحه
بسيطرتهم على هذه المنطقه وتقدمهم في هذه
المنطقه منطقه الابيض على ما يبدو
المواجهات المستمره بين الدعم السريع
والجيش التي دخلت في يومها الثامن
واسبوعها الثاني خلال الثاني ايام عيد
الفطر المبارك رغم اعلان الهدنه اذن مقطع
متداول يظهر تقدم قوات الجيش السوداني في
الابيض في ولايه شمال كردفان في السودان
مشاهدينا نرى عناصر للجيش وهللون ويكبرون
فرحه بتقدمهم وسيطرتهم على هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر تعيش يا ملك
شايفين
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
اذن على الجانب الاخر قال قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدانو المعروف باسم حميتي
قال انه تلقى اتصالا هاتفيا من الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو نشرا الى
انهما ناقش جميع القضايا المتعلقه بالازمه
الراهنه في ضوء الهدنه الانسانيه واهميات
فتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين والمقيمين
واهميه تسهيل حركتهم من اجل الحصول على
المساعدات الممكنه واضاف حميتي انه اكد
على ضروره الالتزام بالوقف الكامل لاطلاق
النار وتوفير الحمايه للعاملين في الحقل
الانساني والطبي لاسيما موظفون الامم
المتحده والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه
كما بحث وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ونظيره البريطاني جيمس
كليفرلي بحثت تطورات في السودان وذلك خلال
اتصال هاتفي واكد وزيره خارجيه السعوديه
وبريطانيا على اهميه وقف التصعيد في
السودان وانهاء اعمال العنف كما شددا على
ضروره توفير الحمايه للمدنيين والمقيمين
في السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات